we're now getting a firsthand look at a
Georgia car chase turned shootout that
left multiple officers injured one
suspect killed and another with a
lifetime prison
sentence
it happened on April 12th 2021 in
Carroll County Georgia West of Atlanta
that's where a Georgia State Patrol
Trooper stopped a Nissan Sentra driving
more than 100 miles hour along the
[Music]
interstate investigators later
determined the driver was Aaron Shelton
his his cousin Pier Shelton was in the
passenger seat as dash camera video
shows at first the driver doesn't stop
for the
[Music]
trooper event though the car pulls to
the side of the
[Music]
road but when the trooper gets out to
approach the Nissan it speeds
off
[Music]
dash camera video shows the initial
Chase as Aaron Shelton attempts to
outrun the
[Music]
trooper
w
soon the trooper gains on Shelton's
vehicle as dash camera video continues
the initial Trooper zeros in on the
suspect's car and Taps it as it drives
along the car veers out of frame before
straightening out once again next Pier
Shelton can be seen from the passenger
side of the Nissan pulling out an
AK-47 he points the gun back at the
Georgia state trooper and open
fire all right shot fire shot as the
chase continues multiple other units
respond to the call including County
sheriff's deputies and local police
officers
[Music]
dash camera video from other First
Responders shows them joined together in
the search for Shelton and his
[Music]
cousin
66 back off of them back off of them
back off let's see what they do dispatch
we're right here going 69 M hour I'm
waiting to see what we do uh we're
turning right on Bank Head
Highway all right get me some people up
here let's get ready to do fony stop if
not we will
pit Carolton police Sergeant Rob
Holloway can be heard on body camera
video calling out instructions during
the chase all right back it off this
back off just a little we're going to
follow at this distance dispatch we are
going 60 MPH Bankhead Highway we're
passing Barn store get Villa set up
spikes at Bay
[Music]
Springs hey just make sure we're backed
off just enough okay I'm going to try to
turn on my seene lights dispatch we are
going about 90 mph we are coming up on
Old Airport Road but only a minute later
shots are fired toward hallway they're
hitting their brakes I'm waiting to see
what they're about to do cheat went back
off of
them you got wor
about I know but I don't want to get up
here while they're moving around I'd
rather go ahead and disable
them Sergeant Holloway was shot in the
head and crashed his squad car as a
result
dash camera video from Holloway squad
car shows the same moments from a
different
[Music]
angle these same moments of Holloway's
crash were also captured by another
officer's dash camera
[Music]
229 somebody check on 229 as the crime
unfolds video shows officers on the
scene take cover ducking behind parked
squad
cars
video then shows some officers move to a
new
location this video shows the
perspective of Carolton police officer
Chase Gordy who also responded to the
scene
Gordy can be seen taking cover in front
of his squad car as shots ring out in
the
distance soon gunshots are fired
directly at
Gordy
Gordy can be seen calling for help as
the gunfire
continues for only two seconds a suspect
is seen in front of the squad car gun in
hand officer Gordy's Body camera video C
captures these same moments from another
perspective he's on my car he's on my
car he's behind my
car in all three First Responders were
shot in injured Gordy Holloway and
Deputy J retto Pier Shelton also died in
the incident Aaron Shelton was arrested
and indicted on 22 counts including
felony murder felony fleeing and
aggravated assault of Law Enforcement
Officers he was later convicted and
sentenced to life in prison without
parole reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra gesy